Russia's President Vladimir Putin has
declared four parts of occupied Ukraine
to be part of Russia the annexation is a
violation of international law in a
ceremony at the Kremlin Putin claimed
the illegal annexation was the choice of
millions who wanted to join the Russian
Federation he added Moscow would defend
its land with all of its means western
leaders have vowed to never recognize
the illegal annexation the largest land
grab in Europe since World War II
Putin had this to say to Ukraine and to
Ukraine's Western allies in his speech
ERS
and their real Masters in the west to
hear me so that everyone remembers that
people living in luhansk Donetsk and
zaporicia are becoming our citizens
forever
and here's how some people in Ukraine
reacted to Putin's illegal annexation
this is a terrorist way of violently
taking away territories that have been
formed and attached to Ukraine a very
long time ago my reaction to this is
sharply negative
[Music]
I am from myself
and I know people who are remaining
there
waiting for Ukraine to return
there's no question about that we just
need to gather strength and be patient
I think what is happening is Lawless
there is no other way to put it
what's most scary and unclear is what
will be next
we have no idea how this will end
that is sad
and earlier we asked our correspondent
Matthias Berlinger and Keith to tell us
more about the Ukrainian government's
reaction to Russia's illegal annexation
well Kiev has already reacted there has
been a a session of the National
Security Council and the immediate
answer by Ukraine is that they have that
they are issuing a demand to uh to
accelerate the uh or or or that they are
asking NATO to take them in into the
alliance in an accelerated process
now many people are concerned about the
possibility of this conflict going
nuclear does this illegal annexation
increase the risk of Putin using a
nuclear weapons
well in the case that the Kremlin would
decide to use a nuclear to use nuclear
weapons this would serve probably as the
pretext because what Russia is saying
now is that any fighting that goes on in
these occupied territories of Ukraine
would be fighting that would be on going
on on Russian territories so they will
now claim Uh Russian territory being
attacked whether this means that it's
more probable that they use something
like this that they they they use a
nuclear weapon on on Ukraine or on some
territory in Ukraine
um this uh it's not it's not that clear
they will make this decision probably
not according to any formal principles
but uh to two main
considerations they will think whether
it will benefit them whether they will
get anything out of it and the second
thing they will think about is whether
they will get away with it
now on the same day that Russia is
illegally annexing parts of Japan Kiev
says Russian forces have fired a missile
on a civilian Convoy in that very same
region what can you tell us about the
early attack
these were cars that were driving
towards the occupied territories there's
one checkpoint currently where people
can cross over between the Occupy
territories and those under control of
the Ukrainian government they were
driving from the city of zapur Asia
towards these territories and they have
been hit as we are hearing by 16 Rockets
that's of course quite a lot and we see
a lot of casualties here more than 20
people dead and more than 30 people
injured in this Convoy that was bringing
Aid onto the occupied territories and
was supposed to bring people on its way
back out of there
now attacks like this and also moscow's
illegal annexation what does it tell us
about how Russia is doing in its war
against Ukraine
well what we've seen in the past few
weeks is that uh the the that Russia has
lost a lot of territory the Ukrainian
counter-offensive in the Harker region
was extremely successful they were able
to take back a lot of territory in very
few days and now
um we are most likely seeing a Siege the
the ring is not fully closed yet but
it's almost closed around the city of
liman that Russia has taken in May and
that is one of the
[Music]
bigger towns in in donbass region and it
would be the first major settlement in
the donbaz region to be taken back by
Ukraine if they can take it back it's uh
it doesn't look very good there for the
Russians who are about to be encircled
there so we might be seeing another
major defeat in this region in the next
few days of course this is a war things
can go one way or the other way but at
the moment it looks like the Russians
are really on the defensive
Matthias building are there reporting
from Keith thank you Matthias
and earlier I spoke to Stefan Meister
from the German Council on Foreign
Relations and I asked him for his
reaction to the Russian president's
announcement today
no I think what is striking is that
Putin does not speak much about the the
next territories but he is mostly
speaking about the conflict between
Russia and the West
but he's blaming the rest for rest for
what is what is going on he's on one
hand offering uh if there if there would
be a willingness on the other side for
negotiations he would be willing but
then he's talking uh most of the time
about how the West wants to to to attack
uh Russia how it is this Rose of Forbes
he speaks about
um also values and principles
um a Russian relation principles so it's
a it's a very classical speech about the
Putin ideology
um and it shows that he's really willing
to further escalate
um the whole conflict and is not willing
to do any negotiations this is does this
sound like it comes from a man who is
still in control
I think most of the people who are
sitting in this room they they can
expect somehow what Putin wants but I
think in the end he decides in the last
moment what he's really doing yeah so
and I think uh he he's somehow out of
control I think he he is really pushing
this forward you can see his emotion
when we saw it today also in the speech
how emotional he is and how how he is
not on the ground also in what what how
his army is suffering
um in in Ukraine and how difficult it
will be even with the mobilization and
with the annexation uh to win further
territory before for the Russian
Federation
rather chillingly uh Putin has set again
that he will use quote any means at his
disposal to defend Russian territory
does that mean uh nuclear weapons
sure I think this is this is part of the
information campaign that he's trying to
threaten Western and special European
societies with nuclear weapons and I
think the risk is there we should not
underestimate this but I cannot imagine
that he will use uh even tactical
nuclear weapons in Ukraine because of
these four territories this might be
different with Crimea yeah if
um Ukraine is trying to get our crane
Crimea back
um but I I think the risk for him also
globally to be isolated are really very
high and also the West would react Earth
much more harshly so I don't think that
this is the time to use nuclear weapons
uh for for Putin
Stefan Meister there from the German
Council on Foreign Relations thank you
very much
thank you